I mean tell us about the dress girl yes  so I actually had another dress and then  my boyfriend and I were getting a belt  for him at the mall and I saw this and I  loved it so this is the last-minute  dress the most wonderful relatable but I  loved it and you know what it matches  his silver fox hair I am yeah it's very  cool I see you two holding hands you're  happy yeah I am happy yeah tonight  nominee I congratulate you so much we  cannot wait to see what will happen for  you if you do take home a statue how you  gonna feel really happy I mean  especially because I made it with my  good friend Jack so it'd be awesome oh  you get back central he's looking at you  like come on girl okay bought that at  the mall off the rack and it fit like  that it makes me want to hurl I actually  i TI i tailored it right there so you  know a little mix and match I don't feel  so bad now making it always live like  wanna go to the mall  [Music]